-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, some big news
out of Washington today.
House Democrats sent
former President Trump
a letter inviting him
to testify under oath
at his impeachment trial.
There's no way
Trump's going to Washington.
In fact, Trump's lawyers already
called this a publicity stunt,
which backfired when Trump
was like, "Okay, now I'm in."
And get this --
after the Screen Actors Guild
criticized Trump last month,
today he sent a letter saying
that he's quitting the union.
Yep.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's out of work
and just quit his union.
Even worse, now if he wants
medical coverage,
he's got to sign up
for Obamacare.
I mean, it just keeps --
It just keeps going.
It's like, "Oh, my God."
Meanwhile, Melania heard
and was like, "Um, Donald,
while we're on the subject
of leaving unions..."
[ Clears throat ]
But check this out.
In the letter,
Trump actually bragged
about his acting credits.
This is real. He wrote,
"I'm very proud of my work
on movies such as
'Home Alone 2,' 'Zoolander,'
and 'Wall Street:
Money Never Sleeps'
and television shows including
The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air.'"
One day, you're the most
powerful man on Earth.
The next, you're bragging
about your one line
in "Home Alone 2."
[ Laughter ]
I forgot Trump
was on "Fresh Prince."
It turns out
he was the third Aunt Viv.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, the Super Bowl
is just a few days away,
but if you're thinking of
throwing a party on Sunday,
you might want to listen to
what Dr. Fauci has to say.
-Absolutely not.
I mean, watch the Super Bowl
on TV, enjoy it,
have a party in your house
with your family.
So, as difficult as that is,
at least this time around,
just lay low and cool it.
-Fauci was like,
"This is about public health
and definitely not
because it's Thursday
and I still haven't
been invited to one.
Just want to make that clear.
But had I been or have I been,
I would not go.
Of course not."
Listen to this, guys.
I read that if the Buccaneers
win on Sunday,
Tom Brady will get
a $500,000 bonus.
When he heard that,
Brady was like, "Golly.
I better start practicing."
[ Laughter ]
It's a $500,000 "incentive."
I don't even understand
why they do this.
Who needs an incentive
to try and win the Super Bowl?
It's like,
"All right. Now I'll try."
When asked why he had that
added to his contract,
Brady said...
"Because it's funny."
[ Laughter ]
Get this. Down in Tampa,
the local news decided
to talk to a 99-year-old
Buccaneers fan.
She's pretty fired up
about the game. Watch this.
-The Bucs
is the ones that I love.
Tom Brady. We did it.
We kicked [bleep].
Now Patrick is coming to our
house to get his [bleep] kicked.
[ Laughter ]
The news anchor was like,
"Wow. I did not think
that we needed the bleep button
for that segment, but, okay."
Yeah, she and Tom go way back.
She was actually
a Patriots cheerleader
during his rookie season.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, she's the only fan
of the Buccaneers
who knew actual buccaneers.
This is interesting.
I heard that each year
a handful of
Super Bowl commercials
are rejected by TV networks.
Either they're too controversial
or just not right
for the big game.
We got our hands on one of them,
and you can see
why it didn't make it, I think.
Take a look.
-Clydesdales. Powerful. Mighty.
And now available
in every scoop of tuna
at Subway.
[ Laughter ]
-That is awful. That is awful.
That is terr-- That is --
That should not --
That should not air.
That should not air
on television.
I agree. Good for them.
That's terrible.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-Check this out.
In Saudi Arabia,
there's a roller coaster
that's opening in 2023
that will travel more than
155 miles per hour.
And they released
a simulation video.
This is real. Watch this.
[ Riders screaming ]
♪♪
You know it's an insane idea
when even the simulated people
are screaming.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
I read about a man in Florida
who was caught trying
to board a flight
with 22 pounds of meth
in his luggage.
Yeah, luggage with
22 pounds of meth,
or, as it's known
in Florida, luggage.
There you go.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And, finally, as I said before,
the Super Bowl is this Sunday
with the Kansas City Chiefs
taking on the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers.
Now, as you know,
after the game,
they give out awards like
Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
before the game.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
-♪ Tonight Show Superlatives ♪
♪♪
Our first player is Chiefs
quarterback Patrick Mahomes.
He was voted...
Next up from the Chiefs
is linebacker Ben Niemann.
He was voted...
Oh, that's...
Here's Bucs tight end
Rob Gronkowski.
He was voted...
Next up from the Bucs
is wide receiver Mike Evans.
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Up next is Chiefs'
Nick Allegretti. He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Up next from the Bucs
is Ross Cockrell.
He was voted...
Achoo!
Next from the Bucs is
Blaine Gabbert. He was voted...
And, finally, from the Bucs
is Tom Brady. He was voted...
There you go. Those are
Super Bowl Superlatives.